so wait do you turn 30 did you do like a
big thing are you are you you did a
thing we we went um to my favorite place
in the world it's a a golf spot in in
Scottsdale Arizona oh um and had some
friends out and we did a little like
golf tournament
um and it was really fun you know the
whole kind of weekend was was birthday
activities
um but I will say 30 you know it hits
different
yeah it's not like wait till 40. yeah
but and I say this knowing like I sound
ridiculous right so I I go into it
knowing full well that someone uh older
than me would say like yeah that you're
ridiculous you're only 30. but the the
jump from like The Hangover at 29 to The
Hangover he was like very real for me
yeah the recovery time it was like this
is not fun I don't like this yeah but I
used to be able to just bounce back and
I was fine and now it's like I I don't
like the way I feel well just so you
know when you get to 40 literally it's
overnight you get out of bed and you're
like why does it why does it hurt like
I'm like I just I just got out of bed I
should feel rested like what's happening
yeah your your actual body I don't know
you're kind of in shape maybe it'll be
different for you
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]